A growing list of prominent executives and companies,...
...many from Silicon Valley, are voicing opposition to Trump's executive order...
...barring Syrian refugees from entering the US,...
...blocking citizens of seven majority Muslim countries...
...from entering the United States for 90 days,...
...and suspending all refugee admission for 120 days.
The opposition ranges from impassioned tweets from Facebook's Mark Zuckerberg...
...and Howard Schultz of Starbucks,...
...to internal memos to staff from the CEOs of Nike and Goldman Sachs.
So how might these and other companies be impacted?
The biggest concern looks to be in the areas of recruitment...
...and retention of employees who fit the profile of those President Trump wants to ban,...
...including Muslims who hail from the affected countries and refugees,...
...as dozens of the most successful tech start-ups in America...
...were founded by first or second-generation Americans.
Banning them could have a chilling effect on the formation of new companies here...
...and the innovation potential of existing companies...
...who consider international employees to be a valuable asset.